Hey guys welcome back i'm Nate with "The King of Random" and today
We're going to try to make a spooky Halloween treat,
in previous videos grant made a silicone mould of a pig's heart and then cast a chocolate heart in it for valentine's day
Now halloween is coming up and I wanted to try to give this coronary confection a haunted twist
This will be a two-for-one project something that can be used as both a decoration and a dessert as I said
There's a twist i'm planning to put on this. I don't just want to make a normal gummy heart
I think that's a little bit too simple so to kick it up to the next level what I'm going to try and do is
Make a beating pumping gummy heart (Bump) (Bump)(Bump)(Bump)(Bump)(Bump)
The first step is to get the mixture cooking the heart mold is pretty big
So let's mix up a giant batch of our gummy syrup. Let's use strawberry for the color
I'll start with three cups of cold water and add one and a half cups of corn syrup
Once the corn syrup is all smoothly mixed into the water. It's time to add 12 packets of gelatine and three large boxes of jell-o
Remember that you need to get all of the gelatin clumps out before you start adding heat
Now that it's all makes let's put it on the stove at medium low temperature
You don't have to mix everything constantly, but make sure you give it a good stir every minute or so
Well that's heating up, let's make a simple pump that will allow our heart to beat once. It's all finished to make this pump
I'm just using a couple of balloons and a length of vinyl tubing the basic strategy is I'm going to have a balloon over either
end of the tube with a little bit of pressure in it that way when I squeeze on one side it will expand on the
other side
Do that for too long you're going to get lightheaded
Just to be sure that this balloon won't pop off from the pressure. Let's secure it with a little bit of electrical tape I
want to be sure that the balloon won't deform or shrink while it's in the warm
gummy mixture so what I'm going to do is fill the balloon and the tube with a little bit of water I
Want the balloon on the other end to be full of water, too
So I'm going to try and fill it up a little ways
Pinch off the neck and then stretch it over the end of the tube. Hopefully I can do that without spilling water everywhere
No promises. I'm using a water bottle for this because my sink faucet is not very well shaped for filling balloons with water
Air out that's good right there pinch that off I
Think I got it!
Let's dry this off, and then we'll use some more electrical tape to secure this one
It's gonna look so cool
Beating dummy heart thump. Dub dub dub dub dub
Looking agreed our gummy mixture is complete
So let's take it off the heat and let it cool down for a few minutes before pouring it into our mold our mixture has
Cooled down a little bit now
I'm gonna try using the spatula to pull some of the foam off of the top of it
So we have a nice clear casting of our heart
The spatulas not working great, I found this in the kitchen
I'm not even entirely sure what you're supposed to use this work, but I bet it's going to work pretty. Well. Oh
Perfect all in one go
Okay time to pour our gummy syrup, and hope that the mold holds it all in nicely here we go
I'm gonna stop. Just a little bit before it fills all the way to put one end of the balloon pump into it a
Little extra syrup flowing out that should be fine there, okay. I think this placement looks good
I'm just gonna use some tape to hold our tube in place
Now just fill the extra space and since the gummy syrup does tend to shrink a little bit as it cools
I'll try and add a little extra
Our gummy heart is cast now
I'm just gonna pop it in the refrigerator and let it cool there for a few hours to let our gummy heart completely solidified
All right our gummy heart and the mold have been in the refrigerator for several hours now, and it is completely cooled so now
It's time to carefully remove our gummy heart from the silicone
See how this piece is
Mm. Stuck to the wood just how it should be I don't know
That's a lot like a fruit roll-up cuz it's so thin
Bab kind of fixed to my teeth will slide the box off carefully fit it over the hose
That's coming off nicely I'm excited about this
Good you can see a gummy heart in there already
Gummy candy is actually fairly tough
So I'm not super worried about it
But I am of course trying to make sure that I don't tear it while I'm removing unmold all this is a huge heart
Holy cow I also want to make sure I don't tear the balloon that would cause problems
Good look good
Yeah, oh
Look at that that is a giant
strawberry flavored gummy heart right there
Look at the details. You've got the veins running through the heart
You've got the I assume one of these is the aorta up here. Oh that looks so cool
Okay, and now we got to do the test. We got to test our pump to see if we can get our heart to beat
It's moving a little bit
It doesn't expand a ton
But there you go if you look over there kind of near where the balloon is you get some good
Pumping action all that looks so good
Let's see I'm gonna try putting it down on the counter. I bet that makes the whole thing
Yep, it just comes alive there you go beating heart right there. Oh?
It's awesome
Pretty fantastic. It's a great color. You can see a little bit of light through it
There's tons of detail and the pumping does work
You can make it sort of just beat in your hand a little bit
But I'm gonna try and make a quick little display to put the heart on that hides the tube a little bit as well
For our display. I'm just gonna use a black paper plate and cup to make a stand for our heart
I don't want the display stands to be quite this tall so first
I'm gonna cut the cup in half that edge is a little rough. I'm gonna clean it up with scissors
That's better all right so a plate will go on there. That's a good height
That'll look good. This is gonna work pretty well so far, but I want to hide the hose a little bit
So I'm going to cut a hole in the bottom of the plate and in the side of the cup so the hose can come
Out the back and not be as invisible
Okay good
I'm not sure if we even need to cut a hole in the cup or not maybe just a little bit of a notch
There we go
Your heart on the stand, and it just moves on its own now
Let's just secure the plate to the cup with a little bit of electrical tape
There we have it guys a giant red gummy heart that can actually beat with a pump
This is the weirdest grossest candy. I think I've ever made, but it works pretty well
I'm pretty excited about that and it's just it looks like a giant heart
I'm so excited to use this for Halloween decoration and treat and
I think the only thing left to do is to see how it is so I'm gonna just take a big bite
out of this giant pumping heart
Mmm
Tastes like I
Don't think it tastes anything like heart tastes like gummy, which is pretty good
There you have it guys
That's how to make a candy gummy heart that can double as both a Halloween decoration and a Halloween treat and as an added bonus
We made it so it can beat in your hand
Thanks so much for joining us for this video, and we look forward to the next one talk to you then
Just what Leonardo DiCaprio did in the revenant?
It was like a liver i'm basically leonardo dicaprio
Well now it's time for open-heart surgery, I'm gonna cut a big slice out of this
Giant heart sliced in half
We have a leaky heart valve, it's spray
Oh, I should have filled this with red water. That would have been great
So much gummy in my mouth at the same time. Oh my god good